personne ne sera surpris d'apprendre que
les mots classes moyennes se trouve
encore une fois sur ce budget qui
étaient présentées par bill morneau le
dernier budget avant l'élection de
l'automne au canada ça devait être le
budget de l'équilibré budgétaire
libéraux avaient promis en 2015
de retour à l'équilibré budgétaire en
2019 2020 on n'est pas là déficit de 19
milliards 800 millions de dollars donc
on repoussent à plus tard ce retour à
l'équilibré
on ne le met pas le gouvernement renault
le ministre des finances bill morneau
assume pleinement que ce gouvernement
demeure en déficit parce qu'il veut
investir justement dans les canadiens
dans l'économie canadienne qui est quand
même des mesures très fondamentales qui
ont été annoncées sur la formation
un conte vous aurez 250 $ par année dans
une forme de conte de formation si vous
en avez besoin durant votre vie travail
vous allez pouvoir aller puiser cet
argent là sous forme de crédit d'impôt
pour vous aider à payer de la formation
collégiale ou de la formation
universitaire pour les aînés on vient
bonifier l'exemption sur le revenu
d'emploi et sur le revenu de travail
pour vous permettre de ne pas être
affectés sur le supplément de revenu
garanti pour que votre supplément de
revenu garanti ne soit pas abaisser les
voitures électriques 5000 $ si vous
achetez une voiture totalement
électrique dans le cadre du québec
s'ajoutent à la somme de 8000 $ qui est
déjà prévue sur l'achat de voitures
électriques et l'assurance médicaments
pour l'ensemble du canada mesure
fondamentalement ni que dans la
transition dans le bureau de transition
vers la création d'une agence d'achats
de médicaments pour que ça vous coûte
moins cher en termes de médicaments
le retard dans les infrastructures se
confirme ya rien pour la ligne bleue
rien pour le tramway de québec pas
d'information là-dessus pas
d'informations sur la compensation qui
est réclamée par certaines provinces
dont le québec dont l'ontario sur
l'accueil des réfugiés
c'est un budget admis électoraliste
diront certains c'est surtout la
fondation de la plateforme des libéraux
pour les élections qui s'orientent